[Musique]
m
c'est une institution ou une de plus qui
s'installe sur votre territoire le ms
l'école normale supérieure fait sa
rentrée dans ce bâtiment flambant neuf
signé renzo piano et c'est son président
qui nous accueillent merci beaucoup
bonjour pierre paul valliot bonjour
merci encore une fois je pense que je ne
rentrais un petit peu compliqué on
imagine déjà il faut s'emparer de ce
nouveau bâtiment qui est magnifique mais
il ya aussi lakovic 19 alors comment
s'est passé votre rentrée bon la rentrée
s'est passée un petit peu dans
l'attitude de lakovic 19 on va pas se
voiler la face
bon en même temps il y avait là
paradoxalement la joie de découvrir ce
bâtiment je n'ai pas peur de dire ça
parce que ce qu'il fera appel et les
collègues autant que les élèves et les
étudiants qui rentrait c'était quand
même les qualités du bâtiment là le
confort immédiat qui pouvait donner donc
ça vous c'est venu un peu contrebalancé
cette cette atmosphère voilà après la
rentrée s'est relativement bien passée
malgré tout dans la mesure où on avait
anticipé beaucoup des difficultés que
peut causer lakovic 19 / une rentrée en
prévoyant un type d'organisation des
cours un type de rentrée qui était
compatible avec les mesures de
distanciation
oui c'est à dire présentiel et aussi
digitale au regard du numérique pour
partie présentiel pour partie et distant
ciel avec une attention sur les demies
jauge dans les salles des dispositifs de
sécurisation
accentuer le gel prévu à l'ensemble de
l'entrée de tous les ans filles de
toutes les salles donc tous de tous les
bâtiments
donc je pense qu'on a pu donner aux
étudiants
le sentiment que la rentrée était bien
maîtrisée bien que ce soit dans un
contexte difficile
un mot de ce bâtiment c'est un peu le
miroir l'image de le n est ce qu'elle
est ce qu'elle a été alors ce qu'elle
est et puisqu'elle veut être est ce
qu'elle va continuer à vouloir être
parce que ce c'est atrium là dans lequel
on se trouve au fond et c'est une sorte
de rue intérieure qui fait à peu près
170 m de long et toutes les entités de
l'école ou presque pas tout à fait tout
mais presque toutes les entités de
l'école donne sur cette atrium aussi
bien en enseignement recherche donc il
ya deux aspects qui sont que ce bâtiment
illustré que cette atrium illustre c'est
le fait que toute l'équipe discipline de
la connaissance sont à proximité les
unes des autres et peuvent se voir la
biologie va voir les mathématiques va
voir l'informatique va voir la chimie il
va voir la physique va voir les sciences
pour l'ingénieur dans leur diversité
donc lie le design donc là on a toutes
les disciplines qui se voit et en même
temps vous allez voir dans ces couloirs
dans cette atrium des salles de cours
des salles de recherche qui sont des
sales vraiment des laboratoires du cnrs
par exemple qui sont imbriqués les uns
dans les autres
on savait que c'est votre première
entrée sur le plateau qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter pour cette première
rentrée pour le ms ce qu'on peut
souhaiter collectivement
enfin à l'école et à ses partenaires
mais c'est de poursuivre la route qu'ils
ont commencé ensemble on a on a ce
classement
on a maintenant une université qui a un
statut expérimental dans lesquelles les
différentes écoles différentes écoles
sont entrés avec un partenariat crise
organise donc il faut que ces chemins
continue il faut qu'il continue dans le
même état d'esprit positif que qui a été
celui qui l'a marqué depuis
depuis quelques années merci beaucoup
pierre-paul zalio merci de nous avoir
accueillis mais je vous en prie
[Musique]